Speaker 1: Donald Trump did a couple of
whacked out interviews, the first of which
is on a platform called Americano, Media or
Americano. In other words, it's a right wing.
It's new. They get like 2000 views, a video.
It's quite wild. It's a right wing American
Spanish language outlet or channel. I don't even
really know what to call it. And this is, I guess,
where Donald Trump is now being interviewed. These
clips are sometimes only getting a couple thousand
views. This particular one has 7000 views. And
this is where Trump's now being interviewed. The
topic of Elon Musk's takeover of Twitter came up.
This has been a big point of contention. Is Trump
going back to Twitter if he is unbanned,
which would of course completely torpedo
truth social? Trump says he's not with truth.
Speaker 3: Social. Yeah. And the opportunity to
have freedom of speech, which is very important
for democracy. Right. And now knowing that Elon
Musk has control of Twitter, do you see that
there is an opportunity for a broader freedom
of speech in this country that can help, you
know, ease up all these ideas and all these
censorship that that, you know, many people have
been submitted to in the past few years. It's very
good that Elon took over Twitter. It was run by
maniacs, radical lunatics. And they were I mean,
it was all bots and fake accounts, a lot of
it. And it was a disaster. Okay. And I had
hundreds of millions of people between Facebook
and Twitter, more than just about anybody else.
And all of a sudden, one day you don't
have your voice anymore. And I created.
Speaker 1: After telling all sorts of corrosive
lies and inciting violence. Right. That's the
little detail he lives. Suddenly my voice
was gone after I did ABCDE, all in violation
of Twitter's terms of service.
Speaker 3: Truth, social. And
it's been amazingly successful.
Speaker 1: It's almost bankrupt.
Speaker 3: Last week, as you saw, it was above
Tic TAC, it was above Twitter. It was a doc.
It's been an amazing success. So, you know, I like
it. I'm staying on truth social. I like it better.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Trump is staying on truth.
Truth Central is where he will be staying.
Donald Trump in a moment. That makes no sense
whatsoever. Says he thinks the search warrant
at Mar a Lago will make Hispanic people
vote for him. But Trump thinks everything
will make Hispanic people vote for him.
Speaker 3: We don't straight in this country
and you're going to end up you are literally
going to end up with a Venezuela on steroids,
meaning a bigger version of Venezuela. And
that's where our country is going. If you
look at what's happening. Yeah, the raid on
Mar a Lago. People were disgusted by it. But
Hispanics saw that as what happened, and many of
them come from countries that we know very well.
Speaker 1: Oh, God. Is he saying that when
a search warrant was served at Mar a Lago,
it was like the abuses of power, corruption
and dictatorial insanity in Venezuela? Is that
is that the argument he's making?
Speaker 3: They said that's what
happened from where they came. It said.
Speaker 1: Oh, god, that is just rich,
completely legal eyes dotted and t's crossed.
Search warrant being executed when there is
so much probable cause. That's like that's
like what Chavez did. That is just wild.
And Trump actually talks more about Venezuela.
Speaker 3: You take a look at Venezuela,
go back 20 years. Venezuela, very prosperous,
rich country. It was the richest country in Latin
America. It was you know, everything was pretty
good. And now you look they don't have water, they
don't have food. They don't have anything. They
have a dictatorship. And on the campaign, I was
saying that if we don't straighten this country,
that you're going to end up you are literally
going to end up with a Venezuela on steroids.
Speaker 1: There you go. And I have to tell you,
Trump finally getting something right. It is
true. I believe in the year 2000, one or 2000,
Venezuela was the most prosperous country
in South America that he he finally stumbled
across a historical fact that is true.
But Trump is now also doing the communism
stuff without understanding a word of it.
Speaker 3: While the American dream will be gone,
the American dream with communism is never
going to be here. And, you know, once it
goes there, it's very hard to bring it back.
Speaker 1: Yes, of course, there are no communists
in positions of power in the United States. There
just aren't any. And then Trump confirming he
doesn't even know what these terms even mean.
Speaker 3: So I think that the election coming
up on the eighth and the following election,
very importantly, which is now think of it,
it's two years away. Right. Right. Quick.
Speaker 1: Quick.
Speaker 3: How it happens. Time flies. I think
if we don't do well in those two elections,
our country is gone. And I really believe we've
passed socialism. You know, we've just stepped
over socialism. We're into communism. That's
what's happening. If you look at the Justice
Department, the FBI, you look at the kind of
things that are going on with law enforcement
and what they are doing. We have forgotten.
Speaker 1: So he's gone from supporting law
enforcement to now that the FBI served a search
warrant at Mar a Lago. Law enforcement is evidence
of communism, about socialism.
Speaker 3: We're into communism.
We're into Soviet Union stuff. It's very bad
and it's very dangerous for this country. And
people are angry about it. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Trump continuing to
have no idea what socialism is, what
communism is, the difference between
the two or whether there's any of it
here in the United States, as orange
and sweaty as ever and even the friendliest
interviews, he just cannot make any sense.